[Music]
[Applause]
hello again yes I'm back
word has been circulating I know that
helen mirren might be taking my place
sorry folks
well I hope you all enjoyed your dinner
what I had I certainly did and the
company that I kept but mine was spent
largely being questioned about the
differences in resolution between
galaxy-class view screens and
constitution class view screens well I
simply answered politely I don't know
what the hell you're talking about
in fact in fact the truth is and I know
that I can be confident that anything I
say here tonight will go no further than
these four walls but I have to tell you
I wouldn't know the difference between a
warp-core breach and the space-time
continuum if they got into bed with me
[Applause]
embarrassing someone once father said in
miles per hour how fast is the
enterprise fly well you know
how did I know not to go down that road
it's sad and pathetic
I apologize John for my pathetic
ignorance however unlike what many of
you may believe helicopters are not just
for round trips from Malibu to Beverly
Hills they can also be used to shoot
beautiful photography but our next
recipients have created a new camera
system that takes aerial photography to
new heights the shot over k1 camera
system represents the cutting edge of
aerial photography it uses an advanced 6
axis gyro stabilized mount and delivers
substantial improvement in versatility
and control the inspiration behind the
design of shot of k1 was bringing in a
lot of new technologies that have become
available and allowed the
cinematographer to get much better shots
high bank angles fast speed and quick
turns are not a problem for the k1 in
the past shooting from a helicopter
required a delicate coordination of the
camera operator and the helicopter pilot
but the shotover gives cinematographers
more freedom the cinematographers
focused on getting the shot paulus
firestone flying and together they can
achieve something where they're at the
max move their creativity is deliver the
shotover can also move the camera in a
way not possible before including
straight down
beautifully and any vibration from the
helicopter is eliminated having a six
axis gimbal allows each of the three
main stabilized axes pan tilt and roll
to be shielded from wind loading and
disturbances which cause jitter it's
carbon-fiber design allows it to be
easily packed as excess baggage on
commercial flights another advance
is the ability to put nearly any camera
and lens combination into the k1
including two cameras for 3d work or
multiple cameras for plate shots the
shotover k1 has been used on dozens of
films including the revenant which won
the Academy Award for cinematography and
this year's nominee dunkirk the exciting
part about our technology advance in
cinematography is that we've been able
to unlock shots that were impossible
before and create something that's new
and amazing
well I I have to break the bad news to
you that the budget didn't allow for a
helicopter here tonight so the winners
of this award will just have to walk up
here like everyone else and to John
Coyle Brad handle
Vica satay and Shane baucom the Academy
presents a scientific and engineering
award for the shot over k1 camera system
[Applause]
[Music]
this is great we would like to express
our deepest and sincere appreciation to
the academy and committee for presenting
us this wonderful award for the
development of the shot over k1 aerial
camera system even though the four of us
myself
Vica satay Shane Beckham and Brad Hearn
Dell are receiving this award it took
many people to help evolve the design
and we'd like to say thank you to all of
them when I started shot over back in
2009 I told these gentlemen that if we
do this right someday we just might win
an award tonight we are receiving the
best award we
[Applause]
we would also like to thank our families
for their support and understanding
during the years of development without
them
we'd have a lot more to do thank you
very much
so you I'd like to extend I think to the
Academy as well and as John mentioned it
takes more than just four people it
obviously the appoint every good man
there's always a bit of woman so I'd
like to thank my wife without her
looking after the family and you know
these things will be possible because
you can't do them on a nine-to-five
workday and then further behind the wife
obvious is the rest of the team and so
I've got a few names here though I need
to call out because without them the k1
wouldn't be the success that is you need
the people pushing the boundaries you
need the photographers the DPS you need
the technicians and the pilots and you
need everyone to be thinking let's do it
differently than we did it last time
and so part of that team and it based in
LA like to thank Catherine Pugh and
David Noll Fred north
Peter Graf hens Burano and villain Gauss
for their ten years of support and then
all the way over from New Zealand where
we're based back in the and the down
down under where it's you know nighttime
now I'd like to thank Brent Duke who's
here and also David brought her
santanico because that three stained
engineers that also put a lot of hours
and effort to this project so and lastly
I know we'd all like to dedicate this to
the Perlman family and the late Alan Poe
and had a dream for this this company in
this product and this is part of the
culmination of that dream so I'd like to
thank the family for the support and we
all miss them and I'm sure nowhere near
as much obviously as they do so thank
you
just quick thanks to mom dad and two
good friends Toria Melita old support
and Cheer sweet guys I would like to
thank my family and my parents my wife
Ashwin II got autonomy and big thanks to
God thank you very much
[Applause]